ladies and gentlemen amy schumer
oh my god
i'm so pumped thank you for having me on
drew oh my god i just loved and admired
you for so long when we were like early
in flower films like everyone at our
production company knew about you we
were obsessed with you
and and then you did
um inside amy schumer and
like i'm thinking about your life amy
and i'm thinking about like you know you
do inside amy schumer and you write
books and if it's like a pandemic you're
like i'm gonna make a cooking show with
my husband you do stand up if you're
pregnant you share it with people in
these really artistic ways um you know
you make expecting amy
um we'll get into the life of life and
bath which i've been watching
and
i almost want advice
from you
for myself and anyone watching like
how do you prolifically
just turn all of your life into
something that is artistic and a shared
experience
well i just first have to say that uh
your support
this is like you know 15 or 20 years ago
with flower films like your company you
were the first one to reach out to me
and want to make something with me i
mean that's really the truth and that's
a big deal whoa whoa i don't know what's
happening with the flag but i loved it
okay
so
so i really and we did this thing that
it was like a a sketch that would have
wound up on
um my sketch show but but we made it
together and it was like about donating
eggs and it was like this really strange
little short film that i made with your
company and also
you have been such a huge inspiration to
me and
and i think you know to everybody yeah
oh my god stop please and so
there is a lot of you in me
yes and i'm sorry that's inappropriate
[Applause]
please i need you inside me um but uh
you know hearing you say it like that it
really does sound like i
i i do
really um
use my own life and mine it for all the
value that and i feel like we all need
to do that in some way you know all
these all this trauma all these life
lessons these joys it's like what are we
learning from it and so it's like just
as therapeutic for me which is why this
book that's coming out that i edited
and helped compile with chrissy
turlington called arrival stories it's
it's 20 different women it's essays
where we
described the births of our children or
the moments that we became mothers oh
thank you wow it's right there um oh my
gosh i haven't even seen it
uh
yeah but we just that like that is
something that
you know
i i think my best friends we hadn't
discussed our births with each other
it's like this thing that that sometimes
gets like buried and as women you're
like
taught to not really share that much and
so you know we're like we're going the
other way with it uh because
it's the talking about it and writing
about it that
that you do start to open yourself up
and sharing these stories is what helps
each other i think and do you think that
you are the person that you put out
there is there something that would like
surprise us about you like you know what
do you do on a saturday if you have no
obligations what are you doing
every night we read the gene and then
chris and i just watched tv
i heard through those are trending i'm
just saying maybe i could come in on
this relationship because that's exactly
what i want to do is like read to my
kids put them to sleep and then binge
binge tv
we have we have room and we are ready
for this change in our relationship what
are we watching right now
um
we were watching the bachelor
and my favorite thing about the bachelor
is they that every time they get to a
new hotel
everyone acts like they've never been to
a hotel before like they definitely get
a deal or something and they're just
like
like okay actually i'll do it here
they're like the first time they walk in
the room they're just like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know and you're like have these have
you seen them never been in a hotel like
this is so weird
[Music]